how howdy-ho reject nation I am Greg
Alba I am John Humphrey we're gonna
watch today from Focus Features the most
dominant production company in the world
captive state official teaser trailer
numero dos now I have just heard about
this movie and apparently there was a
teaser trailer a month ago and what was
recommended to me was to watch both
they're kind of meant to be watched
together so even though this video is
titled teaser trailer number two
reaction we're gonna watch both right
now it's a twofer it's a twofer what is
hidden help anyway before we hop into
this I wanted to say major major major
thanks to everyone who has been
following us on the Stardust app over
there we do reactions 30-second ones
that are also reviews for many a film a
TV show and a trailer you guys should go
follow us now it's free to use and free
to download and we post quite often over
there there's over five coasts maybe
over a hundred intrigued swatches
[Music]
just like a club the field be overfilled
in district nine strong Vera Farmiga
Wow this
[Music]
okay
thank you the purge
man shrimp really turned things around
yeah
well I didn't do that
[Music]
[Music]
that's good sobbing tree let's hop right
into the second one does your eyes
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
Wow
the Dark Phoenix
Wow where's MGK where's Machine Gun
Kelly
machine gun thing I heard about that's
why I decided to watch this trailer
first place wow wow man
I mean Rupert Wyatt he's gonna reboot at
the planet the Apes franchise The Rise
of the Planet of the Apes and you know
no one knows that this is really cool it
does have that like Cloverfield ish vibe
with some new blob camp aesthetic
alienation kind of like that Stephen
sort of rare contagion vibe a little bit
as well they're very like handheld
panicky I think people prefer these kind
of alien invasion movies as opposed to
like what Roland Emmerich might do with
something more subtle that's really in
the perspective of certain main
characters really seeing it from their
point of view that way they're in their
shoes I'm kind of wondering how the
narrative of this will unfold because
these are really cool teaser trailers
yes but it is still one of those alien
invasion movies or looks like from what
we're seeing here that the alien
invasion has already occurred
yeah and oh yeah there which is a really
clean concept that's a cool concept
please rise to greet our legislature
that's very unique as opposed to
something's coming to be in a sci-fi
universe of oh my god we have a new god
yeah that's a really unique concept but
I am wondering what will the narrative
of this be you know because it's like
for them to be doing the national anthem
looks like the government has already
surrendered to them I'm getting a vibe
of you know some kind of rebellion going
on obviously you need a conflict it's
words yeah no it's about how the people
is great actually is really cool
watching both teaser trailers
back-to-back like that cuz they really
play off each other you said a second
one you're like are we gonna see mostly
the same image oh no we're not
yeah you know which is a nice yet
mislead it makes me wonder too about the
overall visual style of the movie too
because some of it is you know movie
perspective some of it seems like
security cameras some of it seems like
dock yeah style so I'm wondering if
they're gonna borrow some of that
district 9 catalog where it's kind of a
mixture of different shooting aesthetics
or whatnot cuz I got like a very strong
district 9 meets Independence Day meets
the purge kind of vibe from yeah well
that's why I'm wondering what's the
narrative gonna be yeah because I think
its aesthetic and it's stylish
flourishes are very cool and I like the
idea of shooting from the ground
perspective of human beings but then
you're also cutting around to what looks
like a government official of John
Goodman and then you got very firm a go
I have no idea who she's playing she's
lorraine warren godzilla yeah go away
bug monster which i did i cut it like
that brief glimpse at the end they look
almost bug like right yeah yeah i like a
good bug alien and i think that black
guy is that Ashton Sanders from
moonlight in here leading the rebellion
yeah so that's me so you got the
rebellion case you got a government
official then you I'm really unsure what
bare America's role is and then you got
Machine Gun Kelly rapping yeah yeah I'm
not sure what this story will be right
now in terms of their marketing
department I think they're doing a
killer job because this is some awesome
ass stuff I feel like anytime I see John
Goodman on screen yeah
pretty tree seems to pick at least
appealing blockbusters even though
he's done that are under it and I'm
still like hey this is pretty engrossing
overall and you definitely showed yeah
so you know I trust his judgment to a
degree that this will be at least neat
yeah you know even if it's not terrific
I like these kind of sci-fi stories
especially in the way how the handle
with their marketing link because it's
easy to see a trailer like this and feel
like oh this is representative of the
times we were able to make things look
like they were just ripped out of your
TV the finale it's it's a crazy alien
but you know who isn't a captive state
who's that our patron of the day shout
out
Taylor Bentley your free man Taylor
Bentley is the man who's been placed our
patron page for a while and last we
talked he was telling me how he landed
himself a girlfriend who's so hot way
out of his league and I was asking him a
question this is back like a month ago
or something he hasn't responded dude
dude bros before hoes seriously dicks
before chicks you're like a totally
different person you get a tattoo and a
girlfriend now it's like I don't even
know you
ignore me don't ignore me I mean stay
pledge for all you know that's cool but
don't ignore my messages man just
because you get a girl that means you
could ignore everyone now I know I've
gotten that complain about me many a
times in the past year but that
shouldn't apply from you it's different
in the immortal words of the flash it's
rude
Greg all right guys well Taylor I hope
you're doing well
I hope you're still with that girlfriend
I hope she did some really triggering
shout out you're getting ready to no
yeah no you guys can't subscribe to the
react nation click that notification
bell and check us on the start oh snap
free download free to use the world is
free that is
not a lie James Bond